okay babbit it's your boss psychobabble
and I'm wearing a tank top okay my
nipples got to be soft once in a while
okay
I know nipples are like the Gateway to
the soul but sometimes he's got to be
comfortable you know anyways you're
playing this game it just came out today
bad day it's free to play on Steam what
are you doing watching this video just
play it anyways if you're watching that
thank you
okay um so next up our part one office
okay options let me just make sure that
that subtitles are on volume turns down
a little bit okay I turn so you can
actually hear my voice okay take it as
that you know and let's say it's always
a hunt to find the subtitles and I've
dumped now it's always a hunt okay maybe
things just um who knows nobody actually
knows in this game okay okay where is my
mouse where's my mouse great great oh I
just saw it I just saw it
okay hold on hon Jesus she says okay
exhaling again I guess I'm gonna load
this up again yeah now that ice she says
okay here's a protip don't go into
system epsilon introduction to Ceres the
next episodes will be more attractive
and have more expansive story game works
your production value got to fix that
system screen know what that will happen
anyways just play this part one office I
think it's about like a journalist
trying to find like an animal no look
you have made a terrible mistake
look dear by doing the voice I think
dark recesses of REM sleep the only
person I have ever loved hangs and the
day has provided me with a chance to
make things right again today everything
will change
mm-hmm like you think in your own game
oh and is this go to your office
as soon as you can needs are agend I spy
with the voice actor shed one second hmm
hello coffee it's obviously like I know
I said the nipples are the gateway to
the soul but coffee is the gateway to
funk 10:43 you know I really like the
art style goddamn it though one thing is
though they're repeating carpet and they
got to get a seamless texture layer
press a to open Martin Preston I'm the
lead camera okay good job this is a
train wreck of the left light incident
okay proceed
- hold up I don't want to sit down just
yet Bebe's sitting down calls you a
blood clot who's that case
yes except the car what's your point
you know you won't be a free man for
long if you want to fire me just do it
okay the thought of disposing of you
occurred to me but that's not why you're
here
hey Dad what so what did you text me in
such a hurry I received reports of
strange occurrences in a forest nearby
any idea of what it might be today all
the seventh the tenth anniversary of the
first experienced case the victim was
last seen heading down forests yeah so
what
well you've been hunting the
supernatural for 20 years now
and I need your services once again you
have to go there and record any
evidences they could give us a lead on
what's going on in that place that's
crazy
dozens have gone missing doing the exact
same thing I'm not going to do it okay
the voice-acting seriously gotta be
effect should be a guy wearing a costume
or someone called Adrian's voice acting
is great this time it's different
it definitely to that place and they
simply vanish that'll chase that yeah I
guess it this must be some freak wearing
a costume or whatever but this guy isn't
just scaring people he's killing them
and I'm not going to do you're getting a
thigh brows if you won't do it for me
and maybe you'll do it for you and
perhaps you'll do it I know about the
incident with your girls the treatment
of a coma is very expensive and you
won't be as afford it for much longer
I'm gonna sell my house my stuff
whatever it takes to keep her oh oh did
you hear that he breathes into the mic
that's no longer assault murder you'll
go down to the killer and you could
place it dead then [ __ ] you got a good
actually my ticket blood to visor to the
wood quite a nice alternative if you
succeed I'll pay for her treatment in
four that's still suicide if you do it
you'll have evidence on how far you went
to keep
and that could save your life and court
that the only charge you'll have a
fixing business today in a free man
and above all saving her I'll do it
good then we have no time to waste go to
the forest I'll give you instructions
once you get back ok this guy has to
figure out what he likes in life he has
pictures of family picture a sunset
picture of an old painting picture of
like a glitchy thing and race cars ok
let me get the camera ok where's the
kids got the keys Bay Bay what is that a
pill how drink this coffee does I get
Weezer and is that and what is that
deadmau5 I don't know what that is let's
get out of here ok let's get out use
that part 1 office already I nobody
knows nobody knows ok
I don't know what there's like scary
theme music I was you're not going to go
on it one bit one minute ok Gideon's
house on the watch the scary music
obviously I'm not even the whoops yet ok
crash Jay to get to the ground floor
rah rah
what's that do you see that
cut two layers of song going on right
now noctus o'clock okay insidious
documentary that stone told harjes on
Tao void garage okay well let me just
check out real quick what's over here
this way to the waiting room
Frank hi baby
it's your husband a shift to little
faster there we go the daily development
new briefs can't write that
okay I see the point in this room but
that's okay
you know nothing not everywhere was made
equally and I kind of let's just get
going okay it's a very a game or a
productive
well they just say get a gun that they
did offer and clapping they see also a
little a boys that day nobody knows
[Music]
screen erotic house Hamas they did a
good job though care somehow I got a met
Holly [ __ ] they got on fixes background
Mauryan is nice and there's okay Nathan
Davis they got a fire that dude
seriously here in Iran this whole thing
Nathan Davis got to go okay he's dealing
when I blame for this
boy he's acting scholar you know this is
like one of the worst games I've ever
played what the hawk song is this what
[Music]
that was weird okay but it is a slender
man clown
Jesus is a slender bank loan it's gotta
be one here
see there's like lines lose on the flash
that you can't see what it is
what the heck okay the one problem is in
this game is that the Oh God
the mouse isn't like locked into the
game
my name is Frank Scotland mom be her go
after darkness jalisa intimacy
but I prefer which Isis
I decided to record these messages
whenever at a bra now I may either walk
back over my son or end up this
templeton course if you found this man
chase s
okay one thing that is driving me
bonkers
the Beast is lurking for me I know it is
I swear I saw it just standing staring
at me I looked away for a second we've
gone simply vanished I've always
believed darkness was real but nobody at
the department took me seriously now I
know I was right and I shouldn't
thrilled at my funky but my fear won't
let me well I don't know that if
darkness is re-elected be known so I'll
hunt you okay look at this this is
pretty bad dad I must find my son eight
pages
but the idea going after deceit always
seemed like a suicide but then my son's
if you're trying to find the eight
pieces one missing
now I have to do the same
there's eight pages what did I say
okay so this is always a slender clown I
have no idea why they told me to
conserve battery there's no battery
meter
what it says okay and also this game
isn't optimized for weird multiple
monitors because my mouth keeps dripping
off onto the second monitor and when I
try and click something it like clicks
out so annoying I can't like toggling it
okay what is that is one right there
I'm probably the first one to come here
without holding a camera I've always
found intriguing how all the videos
recorded by those who don't listen in
this place show up online and I still I
still remember one it's a guy like
getting texts like the wall recording
the audio you keep hearing that a few
hours [ __ ] what is that a now people
actually look for those things cannot
they know these people have gone missing
and could be dead but who's uploading
these videos where they're officers back
at the department watch the tapes they
tried to come to a conclusion but they
couldn't find any the worst is yet to
come as the bastards cut me from the
investigation of my son's case claiming
that I was getting too involved can you
believe such a thing this is the worst
voice acting I have ever heard in any
game okay so better is going so
battery's gone okay henkle in here dude
what is this
what the hell that okay may I'll take
this trail then see what else has he do
I walk in this made the board deals
accountant ever Scott you're my only son
and I won't stop looking for you no
matter what daddy we'll see each other
again but I have no means to tell
whether it'll be here somewhere above
okay I'm just going in circles at this
point and also I don't think there's any
like monsters it's like they like forgot
to put in a lobster do they forget to
put in a monster like I don't know well
the audio is changing a little bit so
is that a goat okay I've done this like
a million times another need to have
that yeah there are certainly no
flashlights left a little battery
indicator would have been nice
okay anything here now I got to keep
going like do it left because my
monitors are the right again I'm looking
looking
okay there's obviously nothing on the
edges it's got to be like inside house
are not one here okay so I just got
murdered sign okay I've been here like
10 times
okay how many do I have
I don't eight do I Drive eight let me go
down this path if I miss anything it's
got to be like in the middle
maybe it's on these trays
what is that yeah
all right I'm doing a little another
look and I'm saying out then I'm calling
it quits the thing did say something
about like Episode one it's just like a
teaser or something you know I'm at a
batteries anybody and more batteries
Jesus
and admit that sounds pretty scary okay
there's nothing here anyway we're going
to end this here this is a I've taken as
an early access game with free so all
right back out